This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In 1950, a three-year-old girl from Tennessee contracted polio. Within days, Diane O'Dell couldn't walk. Then she couldn't breathe. Her life was saved by a miraculous, monstrous device. The iron lung. You are listening to the breath of life, as it is pumped by these tank respirators called iron lung. You are listening to the breath of life as it is pumped by these tank respirators
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。1950年，田纳西州一名三岁女孩患上了小儿麻痹症。几天之内，黛安·奥戴尔就无法行走了。接着，她无法呼吸了。一种奇迹般却又庞大的装置挽救了她的生命。铁肺。你现在听到的是生命的气息，由这些被称为铁肺的罐式呼吸机泵出。你现在听到的是生命的气息，由这些罐式呼吸机泵出
called iron lungs. Over the years, new types of respirators allowed many polio patients to escape the iron lung. Not Diane. She had a spinal condition that made it her only option. So she stayed flat on her back and capsulated from the neck down in the long, noisy, cylindrical
被称为铁肺。多年来，新型呼吸机让许多小儿麻痹症患者得以摆脱铁肺。但黛安不行。她患有一种脊柱疾病，这使铁肺成了她唯一的选择。于是，她在长长、嘈杂、圆柱形的管子里
tube for 58 years. In an interview shortly before her death, Diane said people often had the same blunt reaction about what they would want in her situation. In an interview shortly before her death, Diane said people often had the same blunt reaction about what they would want in her situation. Most of them said, I'd rather be dead. I couldn't live that way. I'd rather be dead. Nobody would rather be dead.
平躺着，从脖子以下被包裹了58年。在去世前不久的一次采访中，黛安说，人们在面对如果自己处于她的境地时，往往会有同样的直率反应。在去世前不久的一次采访中，黛安说，人们在面对如果自己处于她的境地时，往往会有同样的直率反应。他们大多数人说：“我宁愿死。我无法那样生活。我宁愿死。”没有人愿意死。
They think it's the spur of the moment, but there's always tomorrow. There is always tomorrow. Diane saw her choice very differently than the people looking in from the outside. It's one thing to say you would not want to live for 58 years in an iron lung. But that is not the choice that confronted Diane. The choice was always, do you want to see tomorrow? Today we look at how one family grappled with the same question.
他们认为这只是一时冲动，但总会有明天。总会有明天。黛安看待自己选择的方式与局外人截然不同。说你不想在铁肺里生活58年是一回事。但这并不是摆在黛安面前的选择。选择始终是：你想看到明天吗？今天，我们来看看一个家庭是如何应对这个问题的。
Over the decades, they talked deeply about the choices they would want to make in the face of an incurable illness or terrible injury. But when the time came to act on their beliefs, they discovered a question they hadn't considered. What if the seemingly rational choices you prefer when you're healthy no longer make sense to you when you're actually confronting death. Life, Death and our future selves
几十年来，他们深入探讨了在面对绝症或严重伤害时，他们会做出什么样的选择。但当真正需要践行自己的信念时，他们发现了一个从未考虑过的问题。如果你在健康时所偏好的看似理性的选择，在真正面对死亡时却不再有意义了，那该怎么办？生命、死亡与未来的我们
this week on Hidden Brain. The great dining hall at Kenyon College in Ohio looks like the interior of a church. Stained glass windows, soaring arches, huge oak tables. This is where John Rinca first met Stephanie Bowman. Stephanie came strolling in with this magnetic force behind her. And her hair was long and auburn, and she was striding, and she looked very confident. It was 1969.
本周的《隐藏的大脑》。俄亥俄州凯尼恩学院的大餐厅看起来就像教堂的内部。彩色玻璃窗、高耸的拱门、巨大的橡木桌。这就是约翰·林卡第一次见到斯蒂芬妮·鲍曼的地方。斯蒂芬妮走进来时，带着一种磁性的力量。她的头发又长又红，步伐矫健，看起来非常自信。那是1969年。
John was a senior, Stephanie a freshman. A few days later, John ran into her again at a frat party. They started talking over beers. The conversation flowed and never really stopped. By the end of the evening, they'd shared a kiss and made plans to see each other again. Just really, really fascinating and beautiful and different from anybody I'd ever met.
约翰是大四学生，斯蒂芬妮是大一新生。几天后，约翰在一次兄弟会派对上又遇到了她。他们开始边喝啤酒边聊天。谈话流畅，几乎从未停止。那天晚上结束时，他们已经接吻，并计划再次见面。“真的，真的非常迷人、美丽，和我以前见过的任何人都不同。”
And I just wanted to be around her. John was a force himself. He was one of the top college basketball players in the nation, which was extraordinary because he was only 5'9". But he had a special gift, focus and an immense capacity for hard work. He was known for his offensive skills and killer jump shot. That year was magic for both of them. John set a scoring record that remains on the NCAA books, averaging more than 40 points per game. Stephanie reveled in the feeling of
“我只想待在她身边。”约翰本人也是一股力量。他是全国顶尖的大学篮球运动员之一，这非常了不起，因为他只有5英尺9英寸高。但他有一种特殊的天赋：专注力和巨大的吃苦耐劳能力。他以进攻技巧和致命的跳投而闻名。那一年对他们俩来说都很神奇。约翰创下了一项至今仍记录在NCAA名册上的得分纪录，场均超过40分。斯蒂芬妮陶醉于
being on her own for the first time. They were thriving. Both felt it. After graduation, John moved to Boston for a coaching job. Stephanie made regular trips to see him. Maybe she was concerned about me being out there, you know, single in Boston. I don't know. What John did know was that Stephanie made him happy. Stephanie decided she'd rather be with John than in college.
第一次独立生活的感觉。他们过得很充实。两人都有这种感觉。毕业后，约翰搬到波士顿从事教练工作。斯蒂芬妮经常去看他。“也许她担心我在外面，你知道，在波士顿单身。我不知道。”约翰所知道的是，斯蒂芬妮让他感到快乐。斯蒂芬妮决定她宁愿和约翰在一起，也不愿待在大学里。
She wanted to elope, and John agreed. On an April morning in 1971, they walked into Cambridge City Hall and said their vows before a justice of the peace. She was impulsive. I was game. I loved her. All I knew was that I wanted to be around this person because I thought life would be
她想私奔，约翰同意了。1971年4月的一个早晨，他们走进剑桥市政厅，在治安法官面前宣读了誓言。她很冲动。我愿意配合。我爱她。我所知道的就是我想和这个人在一起，因为我觉得生活会是
full. John was 22. Stephanie was 19. The fullness of life lay before them. Four years passed. It was now 1975. John and Stephanie had left Boston and were living near Washington, D.C. to be close to Stephanie's ailing father. Stephanie was now a nurse. She worked in a hospital on a kidney transplant unit. John taught English and coached basketball
充实的。约翰22岁，斯蒂芬妮19岁。充实的生活就在他们面前。四年过去了。现在是1975年。约翰和斯蒂芬妮离开了波士顿，住在华盛顿特区附近，以便靠近斯蒂芬妮生病的父亲。斯蒂芬妮现在是一名护士。她在一家医院的肾移植科工作。约翰教英语并担任篮球教练
at a local high school. Over the Christmas holidays, they flew to Milwaukee to celebrate the New Year with the Rinca clan. John hoped the visit would ease lingering tension around their city hall marriage. John's dad had not been happy about it. On New Year's Eve, they all went out for a big dinner. And when we got home, turned New Year's, dad went to bed, Steph said, I'm gonna go up.
在当地一所高中。圣诞假期期间，他们飞往密尔沃基与林卡家族共度新年。约翰希望这次访问能缓解围绕他们市政厅婚礼的紧张气氛。约翰的父亲对此并不高兴。除夕夜，他们全家出去吃了一顿大餐。当我们回到家，跨年之后，爸爸去睡觉了，斯蒂芬妮说：“我要上楼了。”
I stayed up with my mom and talked. Quarter to one, my dad walked into the room and said, I feel awful. He was pale and struggling to breathe. Luckily, there was a nurse in the house. I went and got Stephanie. Stephanie came in and, Mr. Iggy, Mr. Iggy, get down on the floor.
“我和妈妈待在一起聊天。一点差一刻，我爸爸走进房间说：‘我感觉糟透了。’”他脸色苍白，呼吸困难。幸运的是，家里有一名护士。我去叫了斯蒂芬妮。斯蒂芬妮走进来，说：“伊吉先生，伊吉先生，趴到地板上。”
And he was almost ready to pass out, so she got him down on our dining room floor. And she said, quick, call 911, call 911. John's dad stopped breathing. Stephanie started CPR. I could hear it pounding one two three four five six seven eight nine ten then she breathed one two three four five six seven eight nine and she just kept at it you know just kept at it till they came and relieved her. One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight. One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight. That night, Stephanie saved John's father's life.
他几乎要昏过去了，所以她让他躺在我们的餐厅地板上。她说：“快，打911，打911。”约翰的父亲停止了呼吸。斯蒂芬妮开始做心肺复苏。我能听到它在撞击，一、二、三、四、五、六、七、八、九、十，然后她做人工呼吸，一、二、三、四、五、六、七、八、九，她就这样一直坚持着，你知道，一直坚持到他们来接替她。一、二、三、四、五、六、七、八。一、二、三、四、五、六、七、八。那天晚上，斯蒂芬妮救了约翰父亲的命。
But on the ambulance ride to the hospital, he suffered a second heart attack and then another one in the ER, which led to a stroke. Finally, the doctor stabilized him. But as the family gave thanks, Stephanie pulled John aside. She warned him that his father might be forever changed. This is where I heard quality of life,
但在去医院的救护车上，他遭受了第二次心脏病发作，随后在急诊室又发作了一次，导致了中风。最终，医生稳定了他的病情。但当家人表示感谢时，斯蒂芬妮把约翰拉到一边。她警告他，他的父亲可能永远变了。这就是我听到“生活质量”这个词的地方，
and this is where I heard her espound about people, there's a point where people's life isn't worth living. And of course, these were shocking to me to think about that. That's where I really started to look at this and I looked at my father and I thought, wow, okay, what's his life going to be like? Chester A. Rinca lived for another 10 years, for which John is grateful. But the energetic baseball coach, the vibrant history
也是我听到她阐述关于人们的观点的地方，她说：“在某种程度上，人们的生活是不值得过的。”当然，想到这些让我感到震惊。也就是从那时起，我真正开始审视这个问题，我看着我的父亲，心想：哇，好吧，他的生活会是什么样？切斯特·A·林卡又活了10年，约翰对此心存感激。但那位充满活力的篮球教练，那位充满活力的历史
teacher, he disappeared that night in the hospital. The man who reemerged was frail and vulnerable. It imprinted on me even more this idea of what happens after these moments when medicine can intervene successfully. The experience marked the beginning of an ongoing decades-long conversation between John and Stephanie. They began to consider what it means to save a life at all costs. The questions they were discussing have long occupied patients, families, ethicists, and philosophers.
老师，那天晚上在医院里消失了。重新出现的那个人变得虚弱且脆弱。这让我更加深刻地体会到，当医学能够成功干预后，会发生什么。这段经历标志着约翰和斯蒂芬妮之间长达数十年的持续对话的开始。他们开始思考不惜一切代价挽救生命意味着什么。他们讨论的问题长期以来一直困扰着患者、家庭、伦理学家和哲学家。
What makes life worth living? Is there a point at which you can be alive, but not really alive? Who decides when you reach that point? What if my definition of quality of life is different than yours? Over the years, there were other times when Stephanie and John's musings on life and death became urgent and real. Stephanie's father died of a heart attack. They lost a son right after he was born.
什么让生活值得过？是否存在一个点，让你活着，但并不是真正地活着？当你达到那个点时，谁来决定？如果我对生活质量的定义与你的不同怎么办？多年来，还有其他时候，斯蒂芬妮和约翰对生死的沉思变得紧迫而真实。斯蒂芬妮的父亲死于心脏病。他们刚出生的儿子夭折了。
They got to see life at its worst, but also at its best. They had four healthy sons. Stephanie loved being a mom and John felt he'd found his calling as a teacher and a coach. They moved a lot but to them it was always an adventure. By 1995 they were living up in the mountains of North Carolina in an area known for both its beauty and poverty. Their old farmhouse looked out on a two-lane winding road. We're just about half a mile from what was called Laurel Gap. One Saturday afternoon, John was puttering around outside.
他们看到了生活最糟糕的一面，但也看到了最好的一面。他们有四个健康的儿子。斯蒂芬妮喜欢当妈妈，约翰觉得他找到了作为老师和教练的使命。他们搬了很多次家，但对他们来说，这总是一次冒险。到1995年，他们住在北卡罗来纳州的山区，那里以美丽和贫困著称。他们的老农舍俯瞰着一条双车道的蜿蜒道路。“我们离被称为劳雷尔峡的地方大约半英里。”一个周六下午，约翰在外面忙碌。
Stephanie and the boys were inside. Suddenly, a car sped by going way too fast. And then I heard the squeal of the tires, and then I heard the, you know, very clear and obvious crash into a tree. Stephanie heard it too. She flew out of the house and ran to the car. Inside were three teenagers.
斯蒂芬妮和孩子们在里面。突然，一辆车飞驰而过，速度太快了。然后我听到了轮胎的尖叫声，接着我听到了，你知道，非常清晰且明显的撞树声。斯蒂芬妮也听到了。她冲出房子，跑到车边。里面有三个青少年。
The two up front were okay, saved by the airbags. But the young man who had been in the back hadn't been wearing a seatbelt. And he was wedged underneath a dashboard. Stephanie realized immediately that the young man's head was bent down to his chest in a way that meant he couldn't breathe. So she had to decide, now she told me how conflicted she was with this, she had to decide if I remove him from this position so that he can get air, am I going to cause permanent damage to what might be broken, neck probably.
前面的两个没事，被安全气囊救了。但坐在后面的那个年轻人没系安全带。他被卡在仪表盘下面。斯蒂芬妮立刻意识到，那个年轻人的头弯向胸前，这意味着他无法呼吸。所以她必须决定——现在她告诉我她当时有多矛盾——她必须决定：“如果我把他从这个位置移开以便他能呼吸，我会不会对他可能骨折的地方（可能是脖子）造成永久性损伤？”
Stephanie did what she'd been trained to do. What most of us would do in a moment like that. Do whatever it takes to try and save a life. Get to tomorrow. She moved slowly to get him out so that he could breathe, and then she sat there and held him until the ambulance arrived.
斯蒂芬妮做了她受训要做的事。我们大多数人在那种情况下都会做的事。不惜一切代价去尝试挽救生命。争取明天。她缓慢地移动他，让他能够呼吸，然后她坐在那里抱着他，直到救护车赶到。
But after the emergency crews left, Stephanie didn't celebrate. All she could think of was this, John, I hope he's not paralyzed. I just hope he's not paralyzed. I hope I didn't make it worse. Some weeks later, John was at work one day at the local high school. And this kid came up to me while I was standing in the hall and said,
但在急救人员离开后，斯蒂芬妮并没有庆祝。她满脑子想的都是：“约翰，我希望他没有瘫痪。我只希望他没有瘫痪。我希望我没有让情况变得更糟。”几周后，约翰有一天在当地高中工作。这个孩子在我站在走廊时走过来对我说：
please thank your wife for saving my life. It was a young man from the car crash. He'd not only survived, he was fine. It was the happy ending they'd all wished for. It showed John and Stephanie that heroic medical measures to save a life often do make sense. Stephanie had given another human being decades of tomorrows. There were other times, however, when Stephanie worried that the miraculous tools of modern medicine produced more harm than good. In her work with patients, Stephanie saw cases where medicine saved a life, but left a person
“请感谢你的妻子救了我的命。”那是车祸中的那个年轻人。他不仅活了下来，而且很好。这是他们都希望的圆满结局。这向约翰和斯蒂芬妮证明，挽救生命的英勇医疗措施往往是有意义的。斯蒂芬妮给了另一个人几十个明天。然而，还有其他时候，斯蒂芬妮担心现代医学的神奇工具弊大于利。在与患者的工作中，斯蒂芬妮看到了医学挽救了生命，却让一个人
in unending pain or on permanent life support. When was the suffering too much? We discussed euthanasia, you know, because she had witnessed a lot of things in which she thought, you know, it might have been better for that person to die. Stephanie was always clear on what she would want in the same situation. She didn't want to live if it meant her quality of life was gone.
处于无尽的痛苦中或依靠永久生命维持系统的情况。什么时候痛苦太多了？我们讨论过安乐死，你知道，因为她目睹了很多事情，她认为，你知道，对那个人来说，死亡可能更好。斯蒂芬妮总是很清楚自己在同样情况下想要什么。如果这意味着她的生活质量消失了，她不想活下去。
She would say, John, just shoot me. Don't ever let me get to that point. Just shoot me. I heard that. I heard that. I don't know how many times. She said the same to her oldest son Jason even when he was just a kid. Whenever we would discuss somebody that she'd seen in the emergency room or seen in the hospital,
她会说：“约翰，直接开枪打死我吧。永远不要让我走到那一步。直接开枪打死我。”我听到了。我听到了。不知道多少次。她对她的大儿子杰森也说过同样的话，即使他还是个孩子的时候。每当我们讨论她在急诊室或医院里见到的某个人时，
I distinctly remember her telling me, I don't ever want to be like that. I don't ever want to end up like that. Okay, Mom. So it was clear. Everyone in the family knew it. If, for some unlikely reason, something terrible happened to their strong and healthy mother, if her quality of life was gone, if she was unable to live with dignity, they should let her go. That was what she wanted. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. It was now 2008.
我清楚地记得她告诉我：“我永远不想变成那样。我永远不想最终变成那样。”“好的，妈妈。”所以这很明确。家里每个人都知道。如果因为某种不太可能的原因，他们坚强健康的母亲发生了可怕的事情，如果她的生活质量消失了，如果她无法有尊严地生活，他们应该让她走。那就是她想要的。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。现在是2008年。
Stephanie was 56 and John was 59. They had moved yet again, this time to Wilmington, North Carolina. John was still coaching and teaching. Stephanie had a nursing job two hours away in Raleigh. She worked weekends. One Sunday evening in June, John was reading in the living room, waiting for his wife to return. When she walked into the house, he says, she didn't bother with the greeting. She got right to the point. John, there's something wrong with my speech. I said, no there's not. No John, there's something wrong with my speech. I can feel it. I thought, well Steph, I can't hear it. I mean, trust me, if I heard it, I would tell you.
斯蒂芬妮56岁，约翰59岁。他们又搬家了，这次搬到了北卡罗来纳州的威尔明顿。约翰还在当教练和教书。斯蒂芬妮在两小时外的罗利有一份护理工作。她周末上班。六月的一个周日晚上，约翰在客厅里看书，等待妻子回来。当她走进屋子时，他说，她没有打招呼。她直奔主题。“约翰，我的说话方式有问题。”我说：“不，没有。”“不，约翰，我的说话方式有问题。我能感觉到。”我想，好吧，斯蒂芬妮，我听不出来。我的意思是，相信我，如果我听出来了，我会告诉你的。
Okay. Stephanie let it go. But clearly, it was still on her mind. Whenever she had a free moment, she would go online. And try to diagnose what this could possibly be. An endocrinologist found a benign growth on her thyroid. But when Stephanie asked if it might be causing the speech problem, he responded bluntly.
好的。斯蒂芬妮没再坚持。但显然，这仍然在她心头。每当她有空闲时间，她就会上网。试图诊断这到底可能是什么。一位内分泌学家发现她的甲状腺有一个良性增生。但当斯蒂芬妮问这是否可能是导致说话问题的原因时，他直率地回答：
No, no, no. That's either mycidnia gravis, multiple sclerosis, or ALS. None of those options was good. ALS seemed like the worst. It's a fatal neurological disorder that eventually shuts down muscle control, including the ability to walk, talk, even breathe. But it's extremely rare and affects men more than women. The odds were in Stephanie's favor. Still, even the idea of it terrified her.
“不，不，不。那要么是重症肌无力、多发性硬化症，要么是肌萎缩侧索硬化症（ALS）。”这些选择都不好。ALS看起来是最糟糕的。这是一种致命的神经系统疾病，最终会关闭肌肉控制，包括行走、说话甚至呼吸的能力。但它极其罕见，且男性比女性更易患病。胜算对斯蒂芬妮有利。尽管如此，即使是想到它也让她感到恐惧。
One night, as she was driving to Raleigh, she passed a billboard for the annual walk for ALS. And she called me immediately. I said, hey, Steph, what's up? John, what if I have ALS? I said, calm down. No, John, what if I have ALS? And I could hear the panic in her voice.
一天晚上，当她开车去罗利时，她经过一个ALS年度步行活动的广告牌。她立刻给我打了电话。“嘿，斯蒂芬妮，怎么了？”“约翰，如果我得了ALS怎么办？”我说：“冷静点。”“不，约翰，如果我得了ALS怎么办？”我能听到她声音里的恐慌。
I kept saying, oh, Steph, really, think about the odds. Come on. Let's just see. And I did my rational thing that I had always done with her. I laid it out, what the odds were. I'm doing it for myself as well. And but that had told me it was on her mind. They knew they'd have to keep searching for answers,
我一直说：“哦，斯蒂芬妮，真的，想想概率。来吧。我们看看再说。”我做了我一直对她做的理性分析。我列出了概率。我自己也这样做。但这告诉我，这确实在她心头。他们知道他们必须继续寻找答案，
but decided to wait until after Christmas. Finally, in February 2009, Stephanie made an appointment with a neurologist. John remembers that drive to the clinic. She's extremely somber, and she's listening to this mournful music. The music was from Warren Zivon's last album, which he made as he was dying. You know, this is a haunting mood, let me say that. The neurologist had two tests planned.
但决定等到圣诞节后再说。终于，在2009年2月，斯蒂芬妮预约了一位神经科医生。约翰记得去诊所的那段车程。她极其阴郁，听着忧伤的音乐。音乐来自沃伦·泽冯的最后一张专辑，那是他在临终前制作的。“你知道，这是一种萦绕心头的氛围，我得说。”神经科医生计划进行两项测试。
One is done with electrodes on the surface of the skin. And they run a charge and they see what the reaction to that charge is. That measures that reaction. The neurologist didn't detect any problems. Steph has this tremendous sigh of relief, as do I. And then we get to the other test in which they run a probe subcutaneously and then registers with an electrocurrent response.
一项是用皮肤表面的电极完成的。他们通入电流，观察对电流的反应。这测量了那种反应。神经科医生没有发现任何问题。斯蒂芬妮如释重负，我也是。然后我们进行了另一项测试，他们将探针插入皮下，然后通过电流反应进行记录。
The doctor started on Stephanie's right leg. And she inserts the needle and runs the charge. And Steph goes, how was that one? She goes, good. She goes up to the next point on the right leg and she inserts the charge. And Steph goes, how was that one? Well, not that good. She goes to the third insertion. that good. She goes to the third insertion. And Steph said, how about that one? No, not good. The neurologist continued inserting needles into Stephanie's abdomen, arms, even below her tongue.
医生从斯蒂芬妮的右腿开始。她插入针头并通入电流。斯蒂芬妮问：“那个怎么样？”她说：“好。”她向上移动到右腿的下一个点，并插入电流。斯蒂芬妮问：“那个怎么样？”“嗯，不太好。”她进行了第三次插入。她说：“那个怎么样？”“不，不太好。”神经科医生继续将针头插入斯蒂芬妮的腹部、手臂，甚至舌头下方。
And got this full array of slow registration of muscle response. Stephanie was sobbing through the rest of that. She was just sobbing, trying to muffle. Then the neurologist delivered the words they knew were coming. She believed Stephanie had ALS. Stephanie had ALS. There's no hope. And every day, you get worse. John and Stephanie drove home
并得到了这一整套缓慢的肌肉反应记录。斯蒂芬妮在剩下的时间里一直在抽泣。她只是在抽泣，试图压抑。然后神经科医生说出了他们知道会来的话。她认为斯蒂芬妮患有ALS。斯蒂芬妮患有ALS。没有希望了。而且每一天，你都会变得更糟。约翰和斯蒂芬妮开车回家
and started calling family. Stephanie was eventually diagnosed with a type of ALS that affects swallowing and speech first. She was told she most likely had somewhere between two and five years to live. So in typical Stephanie fashion, she got on with the living right away. She made a cross-country road trip with her two older sons, Jason and Matthew. She took a cruise to the Caribbean with a friend. And then when she came back, she got in the van and took two of her sons down to Florida.
并开始给家人打电话。斯蒂芬妮最终被诊断出患有一种首先影响吞咽和说话的ALS。她被告知她很可能还有两到五年的寿命。所以，以典型的斯蒂芬妮风格，她立刻继续生活。她和两个大儿子杰森和马修进行了一次横跨全国的公路旅行。她和朋友去加勒比海游轮旅行。回来后，她上了面包车，带着两个儿子去了佛罗里达。
And whenever they could, John and Stephanie went to a beach right near their home. A beautiful beach, Fort Fisher. You could walk it for miles. And that she loved. She just, that was her church. This year, you can walk it for miles. And that she loved. That was her church. John had to make some changes as well. He retired from his job and got a long overdue hip replacement. He wanted to be healthy and strong for his wife
只要有机会，约翰和斯蒂芬妮就会去离家很近的海滩。一个美丽的海滩，费舍尔堡。你可以走上几英里。她很喜欢那里。她只是，那是她的教堂。今年，你可以走上几英里。她很喜欢那里。那是她的教堂。约翰也必须做出一些改变。他从工作中退休，并进行了期待已久的髋关节置换手术。他想为妻子保持健康和强壮
because he was going to be there for her every step of the way. He knew exactly what he was aiming for. The most comfortable life, enjoyable life, until it's time to die, and then making sure she died with dignity. Most of that first year after the diagnosis was good. It was nearly impossible to tell that Stephanie
因为他要全程陪伴她。他很清楚自己的目标。最舒适的生活，愉悦的生活，直到死亡来临，然后确保她有尊严地死去。诊断后的第一年大部分时间都很好。几乎不可能看出斯蒂芬妮
was dying. The only signal that something was wrong was her speech. People could now hear what for so long only she could hear. What did you notice about her speech? Oh, slight slurs. Just slight slurs. You know, like one too many drinks slurs, you know, nothing significant. But as the months wore on, she began to have trouble swallowing. We were more and more buying frosties and milkshakes, yogurts. They asked their sons to come home and live with them. Because she wanted her sons around them, so they were all in the house. In August of 2010, 16 months after Stephanie received the diagnosis, she and John went
正在死去。唯一表明有问题的是她的说话方式。人们现在可以听到长期以来只有她自己能听到的东西了。“你注意到她的说话方式有什么变化吗？”“哦，轻微的口齿不清。只是轻微的口齿不清。你知道，就像喝多了酒那种口齿不清，你知道，没什么大不了的。”但随着月份的流逝，她开始吞咽困难。我们越来越多地购买冰沙、奶昔、酸奶。他们让儿子们回家和他们住在一起。因为她想让儿子们在身边，所以他们都住进了房子里。2010年8月，在斯蒂芬妮收到诊断结果16个月后，她和约翰去
on a cruise. Near the end of the trip, they spent a day on a little island. John sat on the beach while Stephanie snorkeled. He knew it was probably the last time she would ever do this. She stayed out a long time, just floating there in the warm blue water. It was kind of one of those moments that made you feel good and made you feel sad at the same time. When they returned, Stephanie had a catheter placed in her chest so John could give her twice daily infusions of an experimental drug. Her swimming days were over. She was getting weaker and thinner.
游轮旅行。行程快结束时，他们在一个小岛上待了一天。约翰坐在海滩上，而斯蒂芬妮在浮潜。他知道这可能是她最后一次做这件事了。她待了很长时间，只是漂浮在温暖的蓝色海水中。这是一种让你感觉良好，同时又让你感到悲伤的时刻。回来后，斯蒂芬妮的胸部被植入了一根导管，这样约翰就可以每天两次为她输注实验性药物。她游泳的日子结束了。她变得越来越虚弱和消瘦。
But still, they were together. John remembers with pleasure their aimless afternoon drives. And we would play Stephanie's music. She loved to listen to Richie Hayden's. Freedom, freedom, freedom. By the end of 2010, Stephanie could no longer really talk. But they still went to the beach. John would hold her arm, and Stephanie would search for shark teeth. I would bend down and pick it up and show it to her and she'd either nod her head or she made, she was making sound, you know, like that, you know, like a slurred speech of yes or no. And if it was a, if it was a shark tooth, I'd put it in my pocket. We ended up with over 7,000 shark teeth by the time this was over.
但他们仍然在一起。约翰愉快地回忆起他们漫无目的的午后兜风。“我们会播放斯蒂芬妮的音乐。她喜欢听里奇·海登的歌。《自由，自由，自由》。”到2010年底，斯蒂芬妮已经无法真正说话了。但他们仍然去海滩。约翰会挽着她的手臂，斯蒂芬妮会寻找鲨鱼牙齿。“我会弯下腰捡起来给她看，她要么点头，要么发出声音，你知道，就像那种口齿不清的‘是’或‘否’。如果是鲨鱼牙齿，我就把它放进兜里。到这一切结束时，我们最终收集了超过7000颗鲨鱼牙齿。”
On one of those beach outings the winter of 2010, Stephanie was walking a few steps away from John. Suddenly, she toppled over. I was stunned because I had never seen her fall. She couldn't throw her hands out. She just fell. The best description would be as if you tipped over a sack and there was a thud and a jar as she hit. And it was like a totally helpless fall. It's hard to imagine what it was like for Stephanie
2010年冬天的一次海滩郊游中，斯蒂芬妮离约翰几步远。突然，她倒下了。我惊呆了，因为我从未见过她摔倒。她无法伸出手。她就这样倒下了。最好的描述就像你把一个麻袋倾倒，当她撞击时发出沉闷的撞击声。那是一次完全无助的摔倒。很难想象斯蒂芬妮当时是什么感觉
losing control of her body. John tried to keep everything positive, to focus on what was good in their lives. I was very reticent to make anything that was uncomfortable brought to her attention at that time. In John's mind, there was no need of it. We weren't dying that day. Everything was positive, everything was for comfort, and everything was for peace. There was not talk about death. There was not talk of death.
失去对自己身体的控制。约翰试图保持一切积极，专注于生活中美好的事物。“当时我非常不愿让她注意到任何不舒服的事情。”在约翰看来，没有必要。“我们那天并没有死。一切都是积极的，一切都是为了舒适，一切都是为了平静。”没有谈论死亡。没有谈论死亡。
That conversation they'd been engaged in for decades receded. In fact, the only time the subject was raised was when they attended ALS clinics at the hospital. Every time we were there and the subject of living will came up or, you know, death arrangements, it was a question asked, would you like to go over your arrangements? She'd say no. She'd shake her head no. And they wouldn't go there, you know.
他们几十年来一直在进行的对话退去了。事实上，唯一提到这个话题的时候是他们去医院的ALS诊所时。每次我们在那里，提到生前预嘱或，你知道，死亡安排，这是一个被问到的问题：“你想过一下你的安排吗？”她会说不。她会摇头说不。他们就不会再提了，你知道。
So that was a little bit of a surprise to me. But again, I was hanging my hat on. She knows what she's going to do. It was one thing to talk about end of life issues when they were hypothetical. All those years of conversations they'd had were earnest and serious, but they were intellectual. Now, death was in the room with them.
所以这对我来说有点意外。但同样，我把希望寄托在：她知道她要做什么。当生前预嘱是假设的时候，谈论临终问题是一回事。他们多年来的对话是真诚和严肃的，但它们是理性的。现在，死亡与他们同在。
Talking about it no longer felt brave and rational. It felt cruel. The abstract had become vivid and that changed everything. It was also the case that there was little time or space to sit down and have an actual conversation. Everyone was overwhelmed by the daily challenges that kept piling up. John and Stephanie's youngest son was still in college. Bills kept pouring in, the medical equipment required tending, and Stephanie kept getting sicker.
谈论它不再感觉勇敢和理性。它感觉很残忍。抽象的东西变得生动，这改变了一切。同样的情况是，几乎没有时间和空间坐下来进行真正的对话。每个人都被不断堆积的日常挑战压得喘不过气来。约翰和斯蒂芬妮最小的儿子还在上大学。账单不断涌入，医疗设备需要照看，而斯蒂芬妮的病情不断恶化。
Among other things, she was losing weight fast. When it became critical, in February 2011, she had a feeding tube inserted. Every two hours, I was feeding her. You know, there's just so much. And amidst all this, you want her to be comfortable. The feeding tube had been a big decision. Some ALS patients choose hospice,
除其他事项外，她的体重下降得很快。当情况变得危急时，在2011年2月，她植入了喂食管。“每两个小时，我就在喂她。你知道，事情太多了。在这一切之中，你希望她感到舒适。”喂食管是一个重大的决定。一些ALS患者选择临终关怀，
where the focus is on controlling pain and suffering, not extending life. But Stephanie was still smiling at John's awkward efforts at nursing, and they were still taking those long walks on the beach. She'd have her long tube tucked in her pants, and when we got back from our walk at the beach we would get in the car and I drove off to the side and I'd get out and I'd fix up the liquid and that would feed her. One of the biggest challenges turned out to be not the feeding tube but the mucus.
重点在于控制疼痛和痛苦，而不是延长生命。但斯蒂芬妮仍然对约翰笨拙的护理努力微笑，他们仍然在海滩上散步。她会把长管塞进裤子里，当我们从海滩散步回来时，我们会上车，我把车开到一边，下车，准备好液体，然后喂她。最大的挑战之一结果不是喂食管，而是粘液。
As the disease took its toll Stephanie had a harder and harder time swallowing and coughing. Those actions need muscles too. So fluids and mucus simply flowed down her throat, sometimes into her lungs. Because she had no gag reflex, she would grab a tissue and put it down in her throat as far as she could go and then let the tissue moisture suck it up. She would throw it in a box and accumulate dozens and dozens of tissues because she would do that until she felt she was clear. John says the fact that Stephanie would do this,
随着疾病的加重，斯蒂芬妮吞咽和咳嗽变得越来越困难。这些动作也需要肌肉。所以液体和粘液直接流进她的喉咙，有时流进她的肺部。因为她没有呕吐反射，她会抓起一张纸巾，尽可能深地塞进喉咙，然后让纸巾吸干水分。她会把它扔进盒子里，积攒了几十张纸巾，因为她会一直这样做，直到她觉得清理干净了。约翰说，斯蒂芬妮会这样做的事实，
put her own hand down her throat to clear out the congestion, was a clue if he'd been able to see it. I didn't see how much she wanted to live. And I think, to be honest with you, she was not preparing herself for death. All of her effort went into her living. And I'm not going to say she was afraid to die. I'm going to say she wanted to live. And there's a big difference.
把自己的手伸进喉咙清理堵塞，如果他能看出来的话，是一个线索。“我没看出她有多想活下去。老实说，我认为她并没有为死亡做准备。她所有的努力都投入到了活着中。我不会说她害怕死亡。我会说她想活下去。这有很大的区别。”
She wasn't working out of a panic. She was working out of a determination. In a way, she had always been like this. Her son Jason remembers when he was in the fifth grade playing in a baseball game. His team was down something like eight to nothing. He went to bat. And there was his mom waving her hands
她不是在恐慌中工作。她是在决心下工作。在某种程度上，她一直都是这样。她的儿子杰森记得他在五年级时参加一场棒球比赛。他的球队落后了大约八比零。他去击球。他的妈妈挥舞着双手
and acting like victory was within reach. It was completely out of proportion to the stakes involved and what was happening in the game. And that was pretty much her in a nutshell. There was always a chance to do something up until the end. So maybe in Stephanie's mind, she thought there would be a way to turn this disease around.
表现得好像胜利就在眼前。这与所涉及的赌注和比赛中发生的事情完全不成比例。这就是她的缩影。直到最后，总有机会做点什么。所以也许在斯蒂芬妮的心里，她认为会有办法扭转这种疾病。
Maybe a new drug or a clinical trial with positive results. The thing is, you never know for sure what is going to happen. Sometimes you save a kid from a car crash and he is paralyzed from the neck down. Another time, the kid you save shows up a month later, totally fine, and thanks you for saving his life. But in that moment when you have to decide what to do, you don't know which way it's going to go. You have to guess.
也许是一种新药或有积极结果的临床试验。问题是，你永远不知道会发生什么。有时你从车祸中救出一个孩子，他脖子以下瘫痪了。另一次，你救的孩子一个月后出现，完全没事，并感谢你救了他的命。但在你必须决定做什么的那一刻，你不知道它会走向何方。你必须猜测。
The Rinker family had to make one of those guesses on a Wednesday at the end of June 2011. John and Jason were watching TV. Stephanie was in her recliner. She seemed to be struggling to clear her throat. Jason asked if she was okay. She indicated she wasn't. She said no. And then Jason said, do you have to go to the emergency room? And she gave
林卡一家在2011年6月底的一个周三不得不做出这样的猜测。约翰和杰森在看电视。斯蒂芬妮坐在躺椅上。她似乎在努力清理喉咙。杰森问她是否还好。她表示她不好。她说不。然后杰森说：“你需要去急诊室吗？”她给了
one of her really weak thumbs up. They rushed her to the ER. Doctors got right to work suctioning out her lungs. They were full of fluid. She was drowning. As soon as her lungs were cleared, they began to refill. And then they started running the tube down again. John stayed close to Stephanie as a respiratory therapist cleared her lungs a second time. The tech, or the respiratory therapist, asked her, didn't consult me, didn't say anything,
一个非常虚弱的竖大拇指。他们把她送到了急诊室。医生立刻开始清理她的肺部。肺里充满了液体。她快要淹死了。一旦她的肺部被清理干净，它们就开始重新充盈。然后他们又开始再次插入管子。约翰紧挨着斯蒂芬妮，呼吸治疗师第二次清理了她的肺部。技术员，或者说呼吸治疗师，问她，没有咨询我，什么也没说，
just kind of spoke over her and said, Mrs. Rinka, if we have to trach you and put you on a ventilator, do you want that? Now this came out of the blue. Jason Rinka was there too, not quite believing what he was hearing. He said, you know, you're permanently going to be attached to this machine that's going to do your breathing for you, and it's not going to be pleasant. This was not how John or Jason had imagined this moment arriving. But here it was. The question that put to the test John and Stephanie's core beliefs.
只是越过她说话，说：“林卡夫人，如果我们必须给你做气管切开术并让你使用呼吸机，你想要吗？”这突如其来。杰森·林卡也在那里，不敢相信他所听到的。他说：“你知道，你将永久连接到这台机器上，它将为你呼吸，而且这不会很愉快。”这不是约翰或杰森想象中这一刻到来的方式。但它就在这里。这个问题考验了约翰和斯蒂芬妮的核心信念。
The choice was clear. Either Stephanie went on a ventilator and continued to live, or she didn't and would die. And she nodded yes. And that's when my jaw dropped. Stephanie wanted to be put on life support. What? No. I just want to say no she doesn't. No, she doesn't want that. She said yes. The procedure would have to be scheduled. John decided he'd bring it up with her again in the morning. Then when she woke up, she seemed to be in pretty good spirits.
选择很明确。要么斯蒂芬妮使用呼吸机并继续活下去，要么她不使用并死去。她点了点头。就在那时，我的下巴惊掉了。斯蒂芬妮想使用生命维持系统。“什么？不。我只想说不，她不想。不，她不想那样。”她说“是”。手术必须安排。约翰决定早上再和她谈谈。然后当她醒来时，她看起来精神不错。
And I returned to the question. I said, Steph, I don't know if you remember last night, but they asked you if you wanted to go on a ventilator, be trach, get a trachea, and go on a ventilator. And I looked at her. You didn't mean that, did you? She shook her head yes. In a very slow nod, I said, now let me get this straight. You want to go on a ventilator?
“我回到了这个问题。我说：‘斯蒂芬妮，我不知道你是否记得昨晚，但他们问你是否想使用呼吸机，做气管切开术，并使用呼吸机。’我看着她。‘你不是那个意思，对吧？’”她摇了摇头。以一种非常缓慢的点头，我说：“现在让我弄清楚。你想使用呼吸机？”
Yes. I'm in a place where I never thought I'd go. And remember, I had prepared for death. It was on my mind every day. So I was much further down the road than she was, and certainly much further down the road than my sons were. John thought that with a little time, Stephanie would choose the course she had always wanted. But the same day, Stephanie went into respiratory failure. She was rushed to the ICU and then into surgery.
“是。”“我处于一个我从未想过会去的地方。记住，我已经为死亡做好了准备。它每天都在我脑海里。所以我比她走得远得多，当然也比我的儿子们走得远得多。”约翰认为，过一段时间，斯蒂芬妮会选择她一直想要的道路。但同一天，斯蒂芬妮出现了呼吸衰竭。她被紧急送往重症监护室，然后进行了手术。
She emerged attached to a ventilator. I did not ever in a million years think that this would happen. John says if Stephanie had been unconscious when they first got to the hospital and they had asked him whether they should put her on a ventilator or choose hospice, he would have had no doubts. He would have said, hospice. I would have felt like I did the right thing. And had they done that and we got to hospice and she managed to regain
她出来时连接着呼吸机。“我一百万年也没想到会发生这种情况。”约翰说，如果斯蒂芬妮在他们第一次到医院时就昏迷了，他们问他是否应该让她使用呼吸机或选择临终关怀，他会毫不怀疑。他会说：“临终关怀。我会觉得我做了正确的事。”如果他们那样做了，我们去了临终关怀，她设法恢复了
consciousness, I would have talked to her and I would have told her what was occurring and I think I could have kept her peaceful and I think she could have left in dignity peacefully and not having brought upon her self and her family just misery. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Jason Rinker has asked himself many times why he didn't follow his mother's longstanding instructions on what she wanted at the end of her life. She had seen too many patients in misery.
意识，我会和她谈谈，我会告诉她发生了什么，我想我可以让她平静下来，我想她可以平静地、有尊严地离开，而不是给自己和家人带来痛苦。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。杰森·林卡多次问自己，为什么他没有遵循母亲关于她临终意愿的长期指示。她见过太多痛苦的病人。
Don't let that happen to me, she'd said. But at the hospital, it was almost as if he didn't have one mother, he had two. There was the rational mom, the experienced nurse, and then there was the mom who was fighting for breath, wanting to live until tomorrow. Jason knows why he stayed silent. We weren't ready. And she wasn't either. What I didn't consider at the time was that you might never be ready until it's to an unbearable point.
“不要让那种事发生在我身上，”她说。但在医院里，几乎就像他没有一个母亲，他有两个。一个是理性的妈妈，经验丰富的护士，另一个是正在为呼吸而战、想要活到明天的妈妈。杰森知道他为什么保持沉默。“我们还没准备好。她也没准备好。我当时没考虑到的是，你可能永远不会准备好，直到达到无法忍受的地步。”
This is hindsight. At that moment, they were all caught up in the momentum of what was happening. While Stephanie was recuperating in the hospital, John and the boys prepared the house. They turned the dining room into what looked like an ICU. There was a hospital bed, tubes and monitors, a generator, and medical supplies. We had all the gauges that read our vital signs. There was a blood pressure reading. There was a heart rate monitor.
这是事后诸葛亮。在那一刻，他们都被正在发生的事情的势头所裹挟。当斯蒂芬妮在医院康复时，约翰和孩子们准备了房子。他们把餐厅变成了看起来像重症监护室的地方。有一张医院病床、管子和监护仪、一台发电机和医疗用品。“我们有所有读取我们生命体征的仪表。有血压读数。有心率监护仪。”
There was a O2-SAT reading from her from her finger that was constantly monitoring her oxygen saturation in her blood. Three weeks after she was hooked up to the vent, Stephanie came home. An entourage came with her. For the first three days, insurance covered the cost of round the clock respiratory care. It gave everyone time, not enough, but some,
“有一个从她手指读取的血氧饱和度读数，不断监测她血液中的氧饱和度。”在连接呼吸机三周后，斯蒂芬妮回家了。随行人员和她一起来了。前三天，保险支付了全天候呼吸护理的费用。这给了每个人时间，虽然不够，但有一些，
to learn how to monitor the new machines and to suction out Stephanie's airways. She was able to communicate a little using an iPad. On the fourth day, the vent team packed up and left. One nurse, Paula, remained on duty. Well, it was about, let's say, 10 o'clock at night. We're on our own for the first time, so we're not comfortable with anything, you know, it's nothing's routine yet. And then, almost immediately, something went wrong. And Stephanie, her O2 set starts to drop.
学习如何监测新机器并清理斯蒂芬妮的气道。她能够使用iPad进行一点交流。第四天，呼吸机团队收拾行李离开了。一名护士，保拉，留下来值班。好吧，大约是晚上10点。我们第一次独自一人，所以我们对任何事情都不舒服，你知道，还没有什么常规。然后，几乎立刻，出了问题。斯蒂芬妮的血氧饱和度开始下降。
What does that mean? Her oxygen saturation in her blood. OK, so we better suction her. The suction device was not easy to use. It demands that you, of course, dislodge the trach, and you run the tube down her trachea but there is a hole at your thumb that you have to cover to create the vacuum. John tried to suction her out. The nurse tried too. Nothing's happening we're not getting any
“那是什么意思？”“她血液中的氧饱和度。好吧，所以我们最好给她吸痰。”吸痰装置并不容易使用。它要求你，当然，移开气管插管，你把管子顺着她的气管插下去，但你的拇指处有一个孔，你必须盖住它才能产生真空。约翰试图给她吸痰。护士也试了。什么也没发生，我们没有得到任何
we're not getting mucus through it. Stephanie's oxygen levels kept dropping. All four sons were in the room now. Jason was standing near the end of the bed, watching, but unable to do anything. And at some point, she started, I guess it was like choking, although with the trach it's somewhat different. And she started to turn blue. John dialed 911. He frantically tried to explain what was going on.
我们没有通过它吸出粘液。斯蒂芬妮的氧气水平持续下降。四个儿子现在都在房间里。杰森站在床尾，看着，但无法做任何事。在某个时刻，她开始，我想就像窒息，尽管有气管插管情况有所不同。她开始变蓝。约翰拨打了911。他疯狂地试图解释发生了什么。
The Rinkas lived near a local firehouse, so help arrived quickly. Two firefighters and five medics poured into the small room. So they were kind of squished near the end of the room. So the room, I believe, had 11 people in it. By that point, Stephanie's oxygen had nearly bottomed out. She needed desperately to have her lungs cleared. But the medics couldn't figure out how to do it. One of the men took the suction, and I'm trying to remember if Paula showed him, but he knew how to get into the trach. No, but he couldn't operate the suction tube because he said it wasn't one like, I'm not
林卡一家住在当地消防站附近，所以救援很快就到了。两名消防员和五名医护人员涌进了这个小房间。他们挤在房间尽头，我估计房间里当时有11个人。那时，斯蒂芬妮的血氧水平几乎降到了谷底。她迫切需要清理肺部，但医护人员不知道该怎么做。其中一个人拿起了吸痰器，我努力回想保拉是否教过他，但他知道怎么进入气管切开处。不，但他不会操作吸痰管，因为他说这不是那种，我不太
used to this kind of suction tube. There was a pause, as if I was expecting somebody else to say, oh let me see it, or someone else to have an alternative, which I can't imagine what it would be. And when I sensed that there was no reaction to that, that's, for want of better terms, I kind of lost my temper. I said, give it to me. I probably didn't even say it that nicely. Give me it. I have this weird determination, anger. Finally something gave way. The suctioning began to work. They got the mucus out. So we put her immediately back on the ventilator, the trach was hooked up,
习惯用这种吸痰管。当时出现了一阵沉默，好像我在期待别人说“哦，让我看看”，或者有人能提出替代方案，但我无法想象还能有什么方案。当我感觉到没有人有反应时，出于缺乏更好的词汇，我发火了。我说：“把它给我。”我可能说得一点也不客气。“给我。”我有一种奇怪的决心和愤怒。终于，有什么东西松动了。吸痰开始起作用了。他们把粘液吸了出来。于是我们立刻让她重新用上呼吸机，气管插管接好了，
her airway was clear, so she was now breathing again. Her oxygen levels quickly went back to normal, her color returned. As quickly as the crisis had started, it ended. The EMTs packed up. One of them patted John on the back as he left. I didn't look at them. And I went back into my room. I sat down. I had one of those office swivel chairs. I leaned back and I said, What the hell have I done?
她的气道通畅了，她又开始呼吸了。她的血氧水平很快恢复正常，脸色也恢复了。危机来得快，去得也快。急救人员收拾好东西。其中一人离开时拍了拍约翰的背。我没有看他们。我回到自己的房间，坐了下来。我坐在一张办公室转椅上。我向后靠去，说道：“我到底做了什么？”
What the hell just happened? What is going on? What did I just do? Did I save a wife? No. I brought a person back to this life. For Jason Rinca, one of the hardest parts was the realization that tomorrow would be even worse. To know that the day that you happened to be on was the best that it was gonna be.
到底发生了什么？这是怎么回事？我刚才做了什么？我救了妻子吗？不。我把一个人带回了这世上。对杰森·林卡来说，最困难的部分之一是意识到明天会更糟。意识到你所经历的这一天，竟然是未来日子里最好的一天。
And that that would be the case for the next day and the next day, that it would always be, the moment that you were experiencing was as good as it would ever be again. After that night, Stephanie lived on, kept alive by machines. But something had changed. She didn't use her iPad anymore.
而且接下来的每一天都会如此，你所经历的这一刻，就是未来能达到的最好状态。那晚之后，斯蒂芬妮活了下来，靠机器维持生命。但有些东西变了。她不再使用iPad了。
She didn't watch TV. I asked doctors, do you think there was brain damage because she lost so much oxygen? Eh, we don't think so. It was that long of a time, blah, blah. I can't believe that. Every day, they don't think so. It wasn't that long of a time, blah, blah. I can't believe that. Every day, they did what needed doing. John would play music and hold Stephanie's hand. He would talk to her about their sons.
她也不看电视。我问医生，你认为她因为缺氧太久而导致脑损伤了吗？“呃，我们不这么认为。时间没那么长，巴拉巴拉。”我无法相信。每天，他们都说不这么认为。时间没那么长，巴拉巴拉。我无法相信。每天，他们都做着该做的事。约翰会播放音乐，握住斯蒂芬妮的手。他会跟她聊他们的儿子们。
She would just lay there in a kind of half stupor. I would come in in the morning at five with my cup of coffee, and I'd sit down and say, good morning, sweetheart. And I would sit next to her and I'd put her hand in my hand and hold it. And she could lift her hand, like from her elbow, she could lift her hand about six or eight inches. And the only thing she'd ever do was would take my hand
她只是半昏迷地躺在那里。我每天早上五点带着咖啡进来，坐下来说：“早上好，亲爱的。”我会坐在她身边，把她的手放在我的手里握住。她能抬起手，从手肘处，她能把手抬起大约六到八英寸。她唯一会做的就是抓住我的手，
and she'd kind of bounce it off the mattress. And I could never figure out what that meant. I still had that feeling. Did I betray her? I still had that feeling. What's going to end? How can we get this to end? I still had that feeling.
然后把它在床垫上弹一下。我一直没弄明白那是什么意思。我仍然有那种感觉。我背叛她了吗？我仍然有那种感觉。这一切什么时候结束？我们怎么才能让它结束？我仍然有那种感觉。
How long does this go on? Finally, in mid-October, three and a half months after Stephanie had been put on a ventilator, a hospice nurse stopped in to check on her. This same nurse had come before. Each visit, she'd spent time alone with Stephanie. Her job was to find out whether Stephanie was ready to die. I don't know what her methods were, but she would come out and say,
这还要持续多久？终于，在十月中旬，斯蒂芬妮使用呼吸机三个半月后，一位临终关怀护士过来查看她的情况。这位护士之前也来过。每次访问，她都会和斯蒂芬妮单独待一会儿。她的工作是查明斯蒂芬妮是否准备好迎接死亡。我不知道她的方法是什么，但她出来后会说，
But she would come out and say it's my feeling that she's not open to going to hospice yet. On this visit she stayed with Stephanie a long time and she came out and she said John I believe I am satisfied that your wife wants to go to hospice. For John, the words brought relief. He signed the paperwork immediately. It was agreed that Stephanie would go to hospice on Monday. They would have one last weekend with her at home. Each of the boys spent some time alone with her. And then it was John's turn. I sat and held her hand and told her I loved her and told her what a great mother she was
但她出来后会说，我觉得她还没准备好接受临终关怀。这次访问中，她和斯蒂芬妮待了很长时间，出来后她说：“约翰，我相信我已经确认你妻子想接受临终关怀了。”对约翰来说，这些话带来了宽慰。他立即签署了文件。双方商定斯蒂芬妮将于周一转入临终关怀机构。他们在家中和她度过了最后一个周末。每个儿子都单独陪了她一会儿。然后轮到约翰了。我坐着握住她的手，告诉她我爱她，告诉她她是一位多么伟大的母亲，
and how much fun we had. And I said, you know, it's been quite a ride that you let me ride with you with, you know. And I did not mention death. I didn't say goodbye and all of those things. I can assure you of that. Late that night, a nurse came by and started a morphine drip. Stephanie lapsed into unconsciousness. The next day, the boys and John stayed close. We just spent the afternoon looking at the pictures and going through this life of a mother who loved her children
我们在一起有多快乐。我说，你知道，你让我陪你走过这一程，真是太棒了。我没有提到死亡。我没有说再见之类的。我可以向你保证。那天深夜，护士过来开始滴注吗啡。斯蒂芬妮陷入了昏迷。第二天，孩子们和约翰一直守在身边。我们只是花了一个下午看照片，回顾这位深爱孩子的母亲的一生，
and who was adventuresome and gave them this life of a mother who loved her children and who was adventuresome and gave them the gifts of creativity and the gifts of wonder and you know who had a you know had an impulsive streak that they that they learned to admire and you know was exciting and and it was just that time you know that's how we spent our time. On Monday Stephanie was transferred to hospice. and it was just that time, you know, that's how we spent our time. On Monday, Stephanie was transferred to hospice. The ventilator was removed.
她富有冒险精神，给予他们创造力的天赋和惊奇的天赋，你知道，她有一种他们学会去欣赏的冲动，你知道，这很令人兴奋，这就是我们度过时光的方式。周一，斯蒂芬妮被转入临终关怀机构。这就是我们度过时光的方式。周一，斯蒂芬妮被转入临终关怀机构。呼吸机被撤掉了。
Very slowly, her oxygen levels began to drop. By the next morning, it was clear that she was near death. John stepped out of the room while a nurse put Stephanie into a clean and comfortable nightgown. John had picked it out himself. A few minutes later, the nurse came out. Mr. Rinko, I'm sorry. I think your wife is dead.
非常缓慢地，她的血氧水平开始下降。到第二天早上，很明显她已濒临死亡。当护士给斯蒂芬妮换上干净舒适的睡袍时，约翰走出了房间。那是约翰亲自挑选的。几分钟后，护士出来了。“林卡先生，我很抱歉。我想你妻子去世了。”
And I got up and I walked into the room, and she was. I mean, you could tell right away, I could tell right away that she was no longer alive, that Stephanie Rinca was no longer. In the months and years after Stephanie's death, John and Jason have reflected deeply on Stephanie's final days and the choices they made as a family. John now sees Stephanie's illness as a two-part event. There was before the ventilator. I would relive any one of those days. I would relive anyone happily.
我站起来走进房间，她确实走了。我的意思是，你可以立刻看出来，我立刻就能看出她已经不再活着了，斯蒂芬妮·林卡已经不在了。在斯蒂芬妮去世后的几个月和几年里，约翰和杰森深刻反思了斯蒂芬妮最后的日子以及他们作为家庭所做的选择。约翰现在将斯蒂芬妮的疾病视为两部分事件。那是使用呼吸机之前。我会乐意重温那段日子的任何一天。我会乐意重温任何一天。
Any of them. Pick anyone randomly. I will be glad to relive it. I will enjoy it. I will savor it much as I did just then. And then there's after the ventilator. There's not one day, not one, after the time she said to go on the vent, not one day you could pay me enough money to go back and visit.
任何一天。随便挑一天。我很乐意重温它。我会享受它。我会像当时那样细细品味。然后是使用呼吸机之后。在那之后，没有一天，哪怕一天，你给我多少钱，我都不愿意回去重温。
Jason Rinker feels the same, but he says the ordeal has left him with some insight into dying. I think the mistake is in thinking that we know how we're going to react to everything. You know, if I were to ask you, at the end of your life, would you like to suffer for two and a half years or would you prefer to go out peacefully on your own terms in hospice? I can't imagine anyone saying, well, I would take the suffering. But when you're in that moment, and I've thought about this so many times, she wasn't necessarily thinking rationally. She was thinking about, well, tomorrow,
杰森·林卡也有同感，但他表示这段经历让他对死亡有了一些洞察。我认为错误在于认为我们知道自己会对一切做出什么反应。你知道，如果我问你，在生命尽头，你是愿意痛苦地活两年半，还是愿意在临终关怀中平静地离开？我无法想象有人会说，好吧，我选择痛苦。但当你身处那一刻时，我思考过很多次，她并不一定是在理性思考。她在想，好吧，明天，
we can deal with the trach tomorrow, we're gonna deal with it tomorrow. I'll have tomorrow, I'll have the next day, not right now. Jason says that when he imagines himself confronting a terminal illness, he understands the dilemma his mother faced. I know what I would say now. I would say, I don't wanna go through that.
我们明天可以处理气管切开的事，我们明天会处理的。我还有明天，我还有后天，不是现在。杰森说，当他想象自己面对绝症时，他理解母亲面临的困境。我现在知道我会说什么了。我会说，我不想经历那个。
I don't wanna be tricked. I don't wanna be a burden on my family. I don't wanna suffer anymore. I wanna let me end it now while my family still has these memories of me. And then I imagine being given that choice sitting across the room from my four-year-old daughter and being asked, are you ready to leave this? You know, across from my wife and being told that this is it.
我不想被欺骗。我不想成为家人的负担。我不想再受苦了。我想现在就结束它，趁我的家人还留着这些关于我的记忆。然后我想象自己坐在四岁女儿对面，被问到“你准备好离开了吗？”时，那种选择。你知道，坐在妻子对面，被告知这就是终点。
So are you ready to say goodbye to these two people that you love so much? As the tools of science and medicine have made it possible for us to extend life, many of us believe we can make rational choices about when to use these tools and for how long. We imagine that we will use medical interventions only to limit the awfulness of death, when in fact these interventions may end up prolonging it. We believe that with forethought and planning, we can force suffering to yield to rationality and logic.
所以你准备好跟这两个你深爱的人说再见了吗？随着科学和医学工具使我们能够延长生命，我们许多人相信我们可以对何时使用这些工具以及使用多久做出理性的选择。我们想象我们将只在限制死亡的痛苦时才使用医疗干预，而事实上这些干预最终可能会延长痛苦。我们相信，通过深思熟虑和规划，我们可以强迫痛苦向理性和逻辑屈服。
Many of us succeed, but many families discover that reason is puny in the face of death. Despite our best intentions, despite all that we know and understand, fear and confusion and love conspire to make neat choices messy and easy decisions difficult. We come to realize there isn't just one person inside each of us. There are many, and these different versions of ourselves have very different desires. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
我们许多人成功了，但许多家庭发现，在死亡面前，理性是微不足道的。尽管我们有最好的初衷，尽管我们了解和理解一切，恐惧、困惑和爱串通一气，使简单的选择变得混乱，使容易的决定变得困难。我们开始意识到，我们每个人内心不止有一个人。有许多个，而这些不同版本的我们有着非常不同的欲望。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoy Hidden Brain and would like to help us make more episodes like this one, please consider joining our podcast subscription. You'll receive access to exclusive interviews you won't hear anywhere else, plus you'll be helping to support the work we do on Hidden Brain. To sign up, go to apple.co. slash hidden brain. Again, that's apple.co. slash hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》并希望帮助我们制作更多这样的剧集，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅。你将获得在其他任何地方都听不到的独家采访，而且你将支持我们在《隐藏的大脑》所做的工作。要注册，请访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。再说一遍，是 apple.co/hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。